here are three crazy Easter eggs that  you missed in one piece and number one  we've got the time to toei animations  made a mistake that no one expected  while animating this scene Tower  accidentally designed this girl with  three legs one two three now number two  it isn't always a mistake that causes an  Easter egg because while designing the  manga for One Piece Oda secretly added  an Easter egg that's a mystery to this  day this Panda character right here has  appeared hundreds of times in the  background throughout one piece but  surprisingly nobody still knows why and  if you thought that was crazy at number  three we've got an Easter egg that's  just plain nasty doing chapter 604 Luffy  picked his nose and then during a panel  with usob we can see a finger with a  booger in the bottom of the frame  finally later in the chapter we can see  that the exact same booger is now on  usob's arm dude  gross